Heute ist es soweit.
Die Marssonde Insight wird auf dem Roten Planeten
landen.
Dabei gelang die letzte erfolgreiche Landung
auf dem Mars 2012.
Sechs Jahre später soll es endlich wieder
einen erefolgreichen Touchdown geben.
Erst 2016 crashte der Marslander Schiaparelli
2016 ungebremst mit 540 Stundenkilometer auf
die Marsoberfläche.
Heute soll ab 20:47 Uhr alles glatt gehen.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videso abonniert den Kanal,
dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen.
Das war wirklich eine absolute Katastrophe
am 19.
Oktober 2016.
Eine Fehlfunktion des Bordcomputers führte
zum Absturz von Schiaparelli.
Der Lander sollte alle Funktionen einer Landung
der Exo Mars Mission der ESA, der Europäischen
Weltraum Agentur testen.
Dieser Test misslang nach allen Regeln der
Kunst.
Statt einer Höhe von 3,7 Kilometern ermittelte
der Bordcomuter minus 2 Kilometer, öffnete
die Bremsfallschirme zu früh und sprengte
das Hitzeschild ab.
Der Marlslander Schiaparelli donnerte mit
540 Kilometern pro Stunde auf den Marsboden.
Totalschaden.
Die ExoMars-Mission ist eine der wichtigsten
Mission der Europäischen Weltraumagentur
ESA.
Trotz dieses Fehlversuches wurden dann auch
die Mittel für die Fortsetzung der ExoMars-Mission
freigegeben, denn die ESA möchte die Chance
nicht verpassen, vielleicht die erste Weltraumorganisation
zu sein, die außerirdisches Leben oder zumindest
früheres außerirdisches Leben im Weltall
nachweisen kann.
Dafür wurde die ExoMars-Mission speziell
entwickelt.
Sie wird einmalige Möglichkeiten bieten und
zum ersten Mal bis zu zwei Meter in die Tiefe
des Mars bohren können.
Hat es dort Leben gegeben oder gibt es dort
noch Leben, sind die Chancen dort am größten
es unter der Oberfläche mit einer Probebohrung
aufzuspüren.
Aber jetzt soll sich erstmal die Marssonde
Insight in den Marsboden graben.
Sie soll ein besonders tiefes Loch bohren,
um den geologischen Aufbau des Mars zu untersuchen.
Bis zu fünf Meter tief soll das Loch werden.
Die teifste Bohrung der Menschheit auf einem
fremden Planeten überhaupt.
Im Bohrloch wird dann der Bohrkopf erwärmt
und es wird gemessen, wie sich die Wärme
im Boden verteilt.
Daraus können sehr detaillierte Erkenntnisse
über den Aufbau des Mars gewonnen werden.
Dieses Heat-Flow-and-Physical-Properties-Package-Instrument
(HP3), wurde im Deutschen Zentrum für Luft-
und Raumfahrt (DLR) in Berlin-Adlershof entwickelt
und gebaut.
Zusätzlich gibt es noch ein Seismoemeter
der der Französischen Raumfahrtagentiúr
CNES.
Hiermit sollen Erdbeben und weitere innere
Aktivitäten auf dem Mars gemessen werden
und somit weitere Erkenntnisse über seine
Struktur gewonnen werden.
Aber jetzt geht es erstmal darum, ob die Sonde
überhaupt heile auf dem Marsboden ankommt.
Um 20:47 Uhr trifft sie auf die dünne Marsatmosphäre
und erhitzt sich dabei auf 1500 Grad Celsius.
Ein Hitzeschild verhindert, dass die Sonde
dabei verglüht.
Durch die starke Reibung wird die Sonde abgebremst
und zwölf Kilometer über dem Boden öffnen
sich dann die Bremsfallschirme.
Ganz zum Schluss zünden kurz die Bremstriebwerke
und Insight landet sanft auf der Marsebene
Elysium Planitia.
Wenn alles gut geht.
Aber nach dem Crash 2016 ist das Missionsteam
verunsichert.
Deswegen heißt es heute am 26.
November 2011 sieben Minuten Hoffen und Bangen.
Bei uns erfahrt ihr natürlich, über WhatsApp,
ob alles geklappt hat.
Damit ihr dort nichts verpasst, einfach hier
draufklicken.
Da bekommt ihr unsere Videos auch vor allen
anderen.
Und auf dem englischen Kanal geht es weiter
mit diesem Thema: Exciting Discovery: Monster
Galaxy has more stars than the Milky Way!
Einfach draufklicken und abonnieren!
Ich also wir sehen uns auf dem englischen
Kanal, denn auch da gibt es spannende Videopremieren.
Also See you soon, stay tuned!